yay just signed with disguised toasts
found roster he may not be back in Tier
1 but with many Esports teams currently
crumbling our creator-backed orgs the
future of the industry
[Music]
before we get into the video I want to
let you know that we've partnered with
Qualcomm Technologies and the team over
at Snapdragon Elite Gaming to explore
the world of mobile Esports our latest
worth episode explores the story of
Bobby and OG two of the best brawl star
players in the world but before they
teamed up they truly hated each other
they had to overcome their differences
to prove that the greatest of enemies
can become the perfect team so check out
the episode using the link below alright
so we were getting dangerously close to
a valorant season without El Diablo and
if you ask me that would have just felt
wrong yay was the best player in the
world throughout 2022 before signing
with Cloud9 back in December and we all
know how that ended the team bombed out
at lock-in and dropped yay and vanity
shortly after I made a video about all
of that back when it happened so make
sure to check it out if you haven't
already but since then we've all
wondered where yay will end up the
roster lock for all partnered VCT teams
was back on March 25th so yay's only
real option was tier 2 and since DSG
dropped exalt last month fans have been
joking around and hoping that toast
would sign yea as a replacement jorg
even joined in on the fun and tweeted on
April fools that they had to drop their
entire roster just to afford yay but
that was only partially a joke because
on Monday DSG posted this video so I'm
looking at your Sentinels contract and
uh
your bio has a lot of zeros am I worth
it
I think I'm gonna have to go with the
free agent of this one
I got someone in mind
okay yeah what's up
you want to join the issue yeah sure why
not following the announcement yay went
live on Twitch and joined forces with
Tarik to farm toast and his friends 2v5
while the three of them amassed over 70
000 viewers and it was honestly nice
seeing yay back on Twitch playing
valorent and just enjoying himself again
we were all worried that he might not
find a home this year but once again
toast has come to the rescue and this
signing is beneficial for both parties
yay can continue to play and get high
level practice and hopefully join a
partner team next year while DSG now has
a better shot at making playoffs in
Split two and viewership for DSG matches
will likely continue to be insane toast
presumably isn't able to offer as high
of a salary as some traditional Orcs but
he is trying to help his players Market
themselves better and create a more
realistic path to profitability toast
even spoke about this in a recent
interview with George Gettys I do try
and talk to my players about like things
they're interested in like I always say
hey if you want to stream with me like
do you want to play games
like with a bunch of streamers and like
teachers like I think Steele did a
really good job like
he coached uh four of us in valorant and
the way his mind works is like it's
something like he genuinely feels a lot
of passionate for like I think he could
have kept doing that for like six hours
for every single map we were playing
like oh this is a sand so this is the
kind of set we want to run yeah and it's
all about figuring out each individual
players like
selling point what toast has done for
the tier 2 valorant scene is honestly
awesome he's bailed out a group of pros
and given them the proper infrastructure
to compete and grow their brands while
the rest of Esports is struggling but
toast has also inspired other creators
like moist critical and Ludwig to invest
in valorent and in a way bail out even
more players I spoke to my boy Danny to
get his thoughts on some of the
creator-backed orgs that his team
competes against then here's what he had
to say I think it's good for the scene
because not only do they provide
viewership but they're also giving free
agent teams a home you know even if it's
for a season or whatever it is like for
example disguise uh for like their game
changers team it was just for the
tournament uh I mean we all saw like the
viewership that they got and it helped
promote game changes in that sense uh I
do think it's very good and if there are
more orgs like that they should jump in
I think it helps not only the scene but
also helps the person running it for
example guys tell us like he's being
watched parties he's having fun with it
I know how's a lot of money but I think
it might be might be worth it so guys
like toast Ludwig and Charlie are
obviously doing good for the community
they're making serious efforts to
establish a route to revenue and make
Esports more sustainable but it's a big
Financial Risk on their part and
unfortunately not every example of this
has worked for a long time it was no
secret that xqc wanted to get into
valorent and sign the turtle troop
roster but things just didn't work out
and last week Governor said that they
were ghosted during negotiations this
guy led us on but for a Montreal
you like drops you guys already
we're never on huh we got term sheets
signed and everything but then it's like
backed out like last second and just
goes to this
we did added a bit more context on
Twitter stating that xqc backed out
because of personal reasons and it
wasn't because they failed to make
playoffs but xqc also spoke about it
last week on his stream I just took kind
of like blindsided and I was embarrassed
and yet at the end
I I definitely I definitely should have
communicated more okay because there are
things that I just couldn't say that and
it would make it would make sense not to
explain it I thought uh okay maybe my
managers are gonna clutch and they will
explain these things because they're the
ones that are talking to them not me
anymore right at that point
and I felt so bad I felt so bad and I
felt so embarrassed about some of this
that I was doing with that
um I I agreed to paying them a month
salary or a half a half month salary
um so the time that they spent waiting
yeah whatever so I would pay them the
full amount and the amounts were pretty
big too so as much as it sucks for the
guys over at Turtle troop at least xqc
was kind enough to pay them some amount
of money for their time spent
negotiating he absolutely didn't have to
do that but he did Turtle troop is the
only remaining unsigned navcl team right
now and that's pretty good compared to
other regions the n a tier 2 scene is a
lot healthier than most even on the game
changers side so hopefully with creators
like toast Ludwig and moist investing in
the scene maybe we'll see others follow
suit and help teams crack the code to
profitability in some of these other
regions
I think a lot of people just expect yay
to come in and like Farm every tier to
your team and I don't think that that's
gonna happen obviously yay is an
incredible player but you still have M80
and like the guard who have been dsg's
Kryptonite I think this is gonna help
DSG it's definitely gonna help them
compete with some of the the big dogs
but I don't think they're gonna suddenly
just like win everything because they
have yay and I know toast doesn't have
those kinds of expectations it's pretty
reasonable expectations which is good